bonjour à tous les lumières qui
illuminent la ville l'odeur du sapin du
vin chaud qui parsèment les marchés et
bien sûr les foules de zombies
consumériste prêt à s'arracher un bras
pour l'heure douzaine d'huîtres depuis
que le réchauffement climatique a mis en
pl ace toute l'ostréiculture
pas de doute c'est noël dit comme ça je
sais plus vraiment si c'est une bonne
chose ou une mauvaise chose je vois pas
du tout ce qui te fait dire ça
aujourd'hui on parle donc de noël mais
par le prisme de la figure controversée
du père noël attend commensacq
controversé j'ai raté le hashtag bijoux
de la mère noël ou quoi rien de tout ça
mais si aujourd'hui le père noël est une
figure rassurante est bien implantée
dans nos coutumes c'est loin d'avoir
toujours été le cas on va faire un saut
dans le temps pour revenir il ya pile 70
ans le 23 décembre 1951 où les
protestations contre le grand barbu sont
tellement fortes que le clergé est même
allé jusqu'à brûlé une effigie du père
noël sur la cathédrale de dijon a
également expliqué faute a carrément et
oui à ce moment là il ya de nombreuses
voix qui s'élèvent contre le vieux
bonhomme s'est notamment des membres du
clergé mais aussi des psychologues et
des associations de parents qui
demandent la mort du père noël c'est un
bon feu s'ils passent par là va bien du
kram et few seconds matin mais qu'est-ce
qui lui reprochent à la fin alors les
parents les psychologues il se demande
surtout si c'est une bonne idée de
mentir aux enfants en leur faisant
croire au père noël mais les plus
remontés c'est clairement l'église qui
lui reprochent de paganese et noël de
paga na kwa à penser pas tous qu'un
rapport avec le kayak donc pas de
pagayer de paganese est de faire de noël
une fête païenne une fête non
chrétiennes mais qu'est ce qu'on s'en
fout de sang
ben justement cette époque qui s'en
foutent pas pour les lys catholique le
24 décembre c'est la fête du petit jésus
et de la natalité il faut dire que ça
fait pas encore 50 ans qui a eu la loi
de séparation de l'église et de l'état
et que bâle les catholiques ici font
toujours par en
tomber comme ça alors déjà il vaut mieux
un peu mauvaise que les crèches sont
interdits dans les écoles alors quand il
voit apparaître un nouveau culte qui
vient remplacer celui du petit jésus et
qui en plus semble directement apportés
les états unis bas autant dire que les
gars ils sont pas mes gars joie ce
bon ok ça se comprend du coup après il
s'est passé quoi cet événement n'est pas
du tout passé inaperçu à l'époque il a
notamment intéressé l'ethnologue claude
lévi strauss qui va profiter de
l'événement pour étudier plus largement
les mutations à l'oeuvre dans la façon
de fêter noël lévi strauss a dit quelque
chose c'est par un personnage dans game
of thrones alors non mais on avait bien
parlé dans l'épisode 2 de sociologues et
lévi-strauss jets d'eau sera qu' on
expliquait que le métier de pneumologues
c'est justement de partir dans des
contrées éloignées pour étudier le
fonctionnement des sociétés et justement
dans le cas du père noël lévi strauss il
va te dire [ __ ] c'est trop génial pour
une fois que j'ai pas un bar et dans un
pays paumé un traité de moustiques ça me
faire des vacances t'es sûr qu'il a
vraiment dit ça comme ça oui non mais je
paraphrase la bon en vrai de vrai il a
dit ce n'est pas tous les jours que
l'ethnologue trouve ainsi l'occasion
d'observer dans sa propre société la
croissance subite d'un rite et même d'un
culte et de rechercher les causes et
d'en étudier l'impact sur les autres
formes de la vie religieuse oui bon ben
c'est pas tout à fait pareil quand même
franchement je vois pas la différence
c'est donc l'année suivante en 1952
qu'il va publier le père noël supplicié
dans la revue les temps modernes et
c'est principalement sur ce texte que je
vais m'appuyer dans cette vidéo il est
facilement trouvable en ligne et il ya
même une version lui en intégralité sur
la chaîne entre au story et tous les
liens sont bien sûr dans la description
[Musique]
m
ce qu'il faut bien avoir en tête c'est
qu'en 1951 le père noël c'est une figure
qui est assez nouvelle en france 1 et
comme souvent ce qui est nouveau ça
génère des réactions qui menacent de
partir un peu en panique morale
seulement deux jours après le bûcher on
peut ainsi entendre l'émission de radio
la tribune de paris où il ya plusieurs
intervenants qui s'insurge contre le
père noël je vous mettre un extrait de
l'intervention de béatrix dussane c'est
une comédienne qui est sociétaire de
l'académie française et qu'est né en
1888 et je trouve son intervention
particulièrement éclairante sur le sujet
c'est que je date d'un temps je m'excuse
où il n'y avait pas de père noël et
pourtant il est bien vieux n'est-ce pas
et bien quand j'étais petite fille mes
cadeaux de noël ont été apportées par le
petit jésus comme à tous les petits
enfants et puis un beau jour j'ai
demandé à mes parents je les ai être
juré de me dire la vérité ils me l'ont
dit je leur ai d'ailleurs reprocher
tendrement du milieu de mes larmes de me
l'avoir dit parce que c'était si beau
que j'aurais bien voulu que ça durera
ceci dit il est très certain que le
petit jésus on ne le voyait pas n'est ce
pas les jouets arrivait dans le silence
dans la nuit dans une sorte de mystère
il n'y avait pas
concrétisation ce qu'il y a maintenant
d'une manière en effet tellement chaud
quand on voit le permet les plus
sûrement plutôt mieux louper non
seulement un même cas mais un homme est
vivant il y en a un dans chaque magasin
alors là je crois que il est possible
que l'enfant quand il grandit quand sa
raison vient
se rendent compte que la tromperie a été
plus grossières jeu gym donne que je
demande je sais que pour ma part je n'ai
pas de souvenir amer de
cette cette acquisition de connaissances
réelles qui consiste à ne plus croire
que c'est le petit jésus qui a porté les
choses dans la cheminée je n'ai pas de
mauvais souvenirs et
lui donna tri actuels site est
exactement on a organisé une loterie à
une publicité si tigana trimestre paraît
beaucoup plus champions j'aime bien cet
extrait parce que bien peu tout dedans
il ya du rejet de la nouveauté de la
volonté de garder les racines
chrétiennes et aussi un peu de mauvaise
foi parce que l'argument visant à dire
que vaut mieux pas raconter de mensonges
aux enfants ils marchent pas très bien
avec le fait de faire croire que c'est
le petit jésus qu'apportent les cadeaux
en fait on voit que le vrai problème
surtout l'abandon d'une tradition qui se
veut assez tic en faveur de pratiques
consumériste importé des états unis
parce que oui hein le père noël à la
base c'est une création purement
américaine ah oui mais j'ai entendu ça
en fait le père noël il avait été créé
par coca cola pour faire de la pub c'est
ça alors non ça c'est un énorme a
raccourci en fait le père noël il vient
de la figure de saint nicolas saint
nicolas c'est un évêque du 4e siècle qui
est devenu le saint patron des marins et
qui était très vénérés par les premiers
colons américains parce que c'était
aussi des marins sa figure elle s'est
ensuite transformé en sibérie dans avec
plusieurs autres croyances et de saint
nicolas il est devenu le santa claus
américain qui distribue des cadeaux par
la cheminée on commence à le représenter
dans les années 1860 avec une grande
barbe blanche et un gros ventre mais
avec des vêtements qui peuvent changer
de couleur on peut avoir du bleu du
jaune du vert mais après c'est bien coca
cola qui a contribué à fixer l'image
définitive qu'on s'en fait aujourd'hui
dans une campagne publicitaire qui elles
datent des années 30 et là on leur
présentait souvent de la taille d'un
petit lutin parce qu'il fallait bien
expliqué qu'ils puissent passer par la
cheminée voilà on leur présente avec une
taille normale
et puis surtout il quittera plus jamais
le fameux habit rouge qui se répand dans
le monde entier en même temps que les
bouteilles de coca cola ok donc même si
c'est pas coca cola qui a inventé le
père noël ce que je comprends de ce que
tu me dis c'est que le père noël panda
aujourd'hui c'est quand même pas mal un
produit de la société de consommation
capitaliste donc c'est pas vraiment
étonnant que les catholiques y voit pas
ça dans mon oeil mais tout à fait
d'autant que lévi-strauss montre que
l'église catholique n'est pas tout à
fait à côté de la plaque quand elle
accuse le père noël d'être une figure
païenne empêcher au plus cher parce que
s'ils dérive effectivement d'un culte
chrétien saint nicolas il apporte
surtout avec lui une forme de
syncrétisme religieux attendant une
forme de sucre et isme sait pas quand on
étudie socrates non ça c'est le socrate
isme je te parle de syncrétisme c'est le
fait que les pratiques actuelles le sont
souvent le mélange de plusieurs
influences et de plusieurs doctrine
disparates qui se réunissent pour créer
quelque chose de nouveau alors je vais
pas rentrer dans les détails mais lévi
strauss il explique par exemple que la
bûche de noël qu'aujourd'hui c'est une
pâtisserie un date en fait de l'époque
médiévale et à l'époque c'était une
vraie buchens c'était juste une bûche
suffisamment grosses pour pouvoir tenir
pendant toute la nuit de noël voilà la
tradition s'est perpétuée
il ya deux trucs un délai fait
saturnales romaines ont trouvé des
décorations avec des rameaux verdoyant
de lierre de ou de sapin comme on a
aujourd'hui et d'autre part sans qu'ils
aient vraiment de lien avec noël là on
trouve dans les romans de la table ronde
un arbre surnaturel couvert de lumière
et bien dans ce contexte là l'arbre de
noël le sapin de noël c'est une solution
syncrétique parce qu'elles concentrent
dans un seul objet toutes les exigences
on a du même coup l'arbre magique le feu
la lumière et la verdure persistante et
on pourrait faire la même chose tu
comprends bien avec la figure du père
noël ouais en fait ce que tu me dis
c'est que dans les fêtes de nouvelles
d'aujourd'hui on peut trouver plein de
béco à des traditions anciennes un petit
peu oublié alors oui mais faut pas non
plus aller trop vite en besogne 1 comme
le souligne lévi strauss lui même il
faut se défier des explications trop
facile par appel automatique aux
vestiges des eaux survivance je
comprends pas l'argument là pourquoi il
faudrait se défier de voir des
survivants ce machin truc là alors
laisse moi t'expliquer en fait c'est
vrai que noël tel qu on le fait
aujourd'hui ça n'existerait probablement
pas si avait pas eu toutes les coutumes
passé mais il faut pas perdre de vue que
si on a inventé noël aujourd'hui c'est
bien pour répondre à un besoin présent
et que ça remplit une fonction dans la
société d'aujourd'hui oui bah c'est
facile de rôle de noël c'est de
permettre de se rassembler en famille et
de garantir un peu de cohésion sociale
c'est la fonction tous les mythes en
fait non et là justement non pour lévi
strauss la fonction de noël c'est bien
plus à comprendre comme une espèce de
rite de passage un rite de passage tu
veux dire un peu comme le fait de
survivre aux baisers pas eu de temps de
jeanine le soir du réveillon alors non
quelque chose de bien plus fondamental
que ça quand même il se trouve que en
essayant de classifier le père noël lévi
strauss il analyse que on peut pas
vraiment le classer parmi les mythes
parce que justement il n'y a aucun mythe
qui rend compte de son origine et de ses
fonctions comme c'est le cas pour
prométhée ou pour eux dit par exemple au
tuer c'est pas non plus un personnage de
légende parce que ben y'a aucun récit
semi historique qui lui est rattaché
enfin il ya bien eu des essais par la
suite comme le film de 2012 les cinq
légendes mais on voit que sévir plus
tardif
du coup ils en arrivent à la conclusion
que cet être immuable éternellement fixé
dans sa forme est définie par une
fonction exclusive et un retour
périodique il relève plutôt de la
famille des divinités donc pour lévi
strauss le père noël est un dieu et
pourquoi pas il est l'objet d'un
véritable culte pour les enfants qui lui
accorde des prières un sous la forme de
la lettre au père noël et puis là il
visait moralisatrice puisque il
récompense les bons et ils privent les
méchants en fait pour lévi strauss le
père noël il a la particularité d'être
la divinité d'une classe d'âge de notre
société est la seule différence entre le
père noël et véritable divinité c'est
que les adultes n'y crois pas et de fait
un aujourd'hui les parents font tout
pour que les enfants croient au père
noël et on compte plus les scandales dès
qu'il ya un journaliste ou même une
campagne publicitaire qui fait des
bourdes à la télé si bien que le père
noël n'existe pas
oui oui cette phrase a fait polémique
d'abord en juin 2010 des parents ont
reproché au crédit mutuel de casser les
rêves de leurs enfants la marque a alors
décidé de ne diffuser ce spot qu'à
partir de 20h30 mais cela n'a pas suffi
puisque le 31 octobre 2010 veille de
jour férié en période de vacances la
publicité a été diffusée sur tf1 juste
avant ratatouille et là c'est le
scandale les articles sur le sujet se
multiplient des comptes facebook secret
et des parents envoient des réclamations
à l'autorité de régulation
professionnelle de la publicité et
saisissent le jury de déontologie
publicitaire teint mais sans déconner
pour faire un bordel pareil pour des
pubs faut vraiment pas avoir de vie le
père noël s'est donc l'expression d'un
statut différentiel entre les petits
enfants d'une part et les adolescents et
les adultes d'autre part et cette
frontière symbolique entre deux mondes
elle est en fait très connue des
ethnologues parce que c'est justement
cette frontière qu'on franchit pendant
ce qu'on appelle les rites d'initiation
dans les sociétés polynésiennes par
exemple le premier tatouage c'est un
rite de passage de l'âge adulte et dans
nos sociétés modernes on pourrait dire
que l'acquisition du permis de conduire
du baccalauréat ou même l'obtention du
droit de vote ça remplit le même genre
de fonction c'est un rite de passage à
l'âge adulte et bien pour lévi strauss
on pourrait également dire que
aujourd'hui c'est cette croire au père
noël ça fait en fait partie d'un rite de
passage qui consiste à sortir de la
petite enfance d'accord donc en fait on
fait croire aux enfants père noël dans
le seul et unique but de leur briser
littéralement leur enfance le jour où
ils apprennent la vérité
superbe alors non c'est loin d'être le
seul but en fait comme la plupart des
rites d'initiation la croyance au père
noël a de réelles fonctions pratiques
qui permettent notamment de conserver
l'ordre social on s'assure en de
l'obéissance des non initiés pendant
toute l'année on rappelle aux enfants
que bassil son passage le père noël va
passer et de l'autre côté le fait
d'avoir un moment parfaitement définis
dans l'année où les enfants ont le droit
d'exiger des cadeaux ça permet d'éviter
les revendications incessantes tout au
long de l'année un jeu des canaux gelés
des cadeaux tout ça mais c'est encore
plus horrible ce que tu me racontes donc
en train de me dire que la toux tout
l'esprit de noël c'est juste là pour
créer encore plus de contrôle social
pourquoi pas créer une police de noël
tant qu on y est et oui désolé de casser
tes illusions mais il n'y a pas
d'échappatoire possible comme narguer
l'isthme une société ça cherche avant
tout à se perpétuer du coup c'est normal
qu'elles mettent en place des soupapes
qui peuvent donner l'impression qu'on
s'en échappe mais qui sont en fait
d'autres éléments qui permettent cette
perpétuation la prophétie était à mon
sujet
l'élu n'est pas là pour terminer quoi
que ce soit
ce n'était qu'un autre système de
contrôle
n'ont jamais je ne croirai ça
et voilà c'est tout ce que je voulais
vous raconter sur le père noël j'aime
beaucoup un ce petit texte de les listes
rose parce que justement il nous invite
à remettre de l'étonnement dans
l'observation de nos pratiques
quotidiennes il montre notamment qu' il
n'y a pas forcément besoin de partir à
l'autre bout du monde pour observer des
rites d'initiation qui porte une
fonction symbolique forte au sein de la
société et on voit aussi que ben en fait
la plupart de nos coutumes même les plus
récentes sont à la fois des survivances
et des réinterprétations syncrétique des
pratiques sociales plus anciennes alors
en fait il ya encore bien autre chose
dans le tech de lévi strauss dans la
suite il montre notamment que
l'opposition entre le groupe des initiés
et des non initiés il peut aussi se
comprendre comme une réinterprétation de
la frontière entre le monde des morts et
le monde des vivants mais bon cette
vidéo est déjà bien assez longue et ça
pourrait éventuellement faire l'objet
d'une autre vidéo dites moi dans les
commentaires si ça vous intéresserait et
pour les plus curieux d'entre vous je
vous renvoie directement au texte
inquiets très clair très bien écrit et
en plus ce qui est très court ça ce
n'est en moins d'une heure et comme vous
l'a dit en plus on peut en trouver la
lecture complète sur la chaîne dans true
story je vous souhaite de très bonnes
fêtes de fin d'année et à très vite pour
de nouvelles vidéos cela on attend
toujours
justement c'est ma résolution 2022 de
faire plus de vidéos donc abonnez vous
si vous voulez pas manquer la vidéo
suivante et moi je me dis prenez soin de
vous et à très vite ciao
haut
ulrich mühe
[Musique]